in this lesson we're going to discuss
the amazing chemistry that pyridoxal
phosphate or PLP can carry out this
vitamin b6 derived coenzyme contains a
pyridine ring and this accounts for much
of the very cool chemistry that goes on
with it
as with many vitamins humans cannot
biosynthesize this we've evolved to not
have the genes anymore to be able to
make this count huh so we rely on our
diet to obtain this important coenzyme
once PLP becomes bound to its protein it
forms a covalent bond
so this aldehyde undergoes conversion to
an amine by condensing with a side chain
of a lysine residue this amine can form
a hydrogen bond now with the O H group
I've just flipped this structure over
and we're showing this dotted bond right
here to show that a hydrogen bond forms
this is a nice six membered ring the
phosphate group becomes ionized at
biological pH as usual and if I add a
proton onto the nitrogen the pKa of this
is 8.3 3 now the pH in your cells is
just going to be a bit more acidic than
this so this pyridine will exist as the
pyridinium ion and this is what gives
rise to the really cool chemistry we're
going to look at the mechanism for
transamination and this is shown here we
have an amino acid with the r group
abbreviated just as r so this is a
generic amino acid this is going to
transfer the amine portion to alpha
ketoglutarate replacing this carbonyl
with the amine this produces glutamic
acid and also it produces a new carbonyl
compound if you think about just maybe
tilting this back a little bit you can
see that the R and the co2 from this
initial amino acid are mapping on here
but this amine has been replaced by a
carbonyl so we're trans emanating
transferring the amine to this new
compound and let
go ahead and look at how PLP catalyzes
this chemistry this is a long mechanism
so I'm going to break it up into three
stages so our first goal in this
mechanism is to add in our amino acid
this one and remove lysine from PLP so
I'm gonna try to color code this process
we'll see if I can keep it up throughout
the whole video so we've our purple
amino acid and we're going to kick off
our pink lysine I've shortened the chain
just a little bit to make it a little
smaller here we're gonna try to kick off
this pink portion and get this attached
via the nucleophilic amine over here
where the lysine was I want to point out
that amino acids are zwitterions
at biological pH I'm just showing this
with it's available pair of electrons in
the active site probably there is a
basic amino acid residue that does this
deprotonation but we're just gonna start
with nitrogen having an available pair
of electrons to show the mechanism a
little easier so I've added on my lone
pair this is going to attack at the
amine carbon and because this is in
close proximity we saw this little
dotted bond showing there's a hydrogen
bond here these electrons can move out
and grab this proton because it's in
perfect proximity to make this nice six
membered ring here
now we want to kick lysine off as the
leaving group so we want to get the
positive charge onto this nitrogen so
that we have a good leaving group it can
leave as NH 2 and we want to get the
positive charge off of this so that we
can use electrons to push out this group
so we'll use a basic enzyme residue to
deprotonate this side and an acidic
enzyme residue to protonate this
nitrogen this carefully position base
will deprotonate here and our acidic
residue will be deprotonated by this
nitrogen now the lysine residue that we
need to kick out is protonated I flipped
the bottom part of PLP right here so
that this oxygen is in close proximity
to this hydrogen because we can show
that doing the deprotonation to get its
proton back let's see how we push arrows
to kick this group out so let's start at
this nucleophilic oxygen will remove
this hydrogen these electrons will come
in making a double bond and this can
grab a lone pair on its way out
neutralizing the positive charge so at
this point we've completed stage one our
new amino acid is added to the molecule
and lysine has been removed now stage 2
is going to involve deprotonation of our
amino acid but we need to prep this
molecule notice that our amine is
turning into a carbonyl so we need to
prepare this so that water can attack
and this oxygen here is going to come
from a molecule of water but there's no
way that we can replace the nitrogen
with anything right now so the first
thing that's going to happen is removal
of this proton now some textbooks just
show deprotonation of this hydrogen
pushing its electrons and then grab a
proton with this double bond but I'm
going to show you just a little bit more
resonance so we can see why this proton
has suddenly become acidic it's actually
part when it's deprotonated the
electrons become part of an extended
conjugated system that goes throughout
the entire PLP ring so we can capitalize
on the
charged nitrogen to accept electrons
through the system and that's what
really is making this acidic so let's
show that whole resonance we need a
basic enzyme residue to do the
deprotonation
so this grabs this proton these
electrons will form a bond here and then
we can show this pushing down these
electrons pushing over here and this
bond becoming a lone pair on nitrogen
giving it back electrons which
neutralizes the positive charge and now
we want PLP to become aromatic again and
so we'll show this arrow pushing and
we're gonna just protonate here so I'm
going to show an acidic enzyme residue
in the interest of space I've
abbreviated this a little differently
I'm just trying to show that hanging off
the enzyme with that squiggly line so
now we can push electrons back the way
they came protonating this double bond
and putting the electrons onto the basic
enzyme residue now we have our amino
acid attached we have a double bond here
that can undergo attack and this is
going to set us up for the third stage
of our reaction which is hydrolysis a
molecule of water will attack here so
this water is going to correspond to the
carbonyl oxygen here we're going to
deprotonate this hydrogen as water
attacks so we don't we can avoid having
an oxonium ion forming in biological
systems which isn't really is too acidic
to be compatible for life so we'll show
this deprotonation attack here and this
double bond will open up and become
protonated by PLP
now all we need to do is deprotonate
here and kick off this Ameen we'll use
the enzyme to do this this basic residue
grabs the proton will form our carbonyl
and this is going to grab this proton of
course this in the three dimensional
active site this hydrogen will be very
close and available and not quite so far
away here we've generated pyridoxamine
phosphate and we've made our carbonyl
compound this compound can be
abbreviated as PMP now I'm going to wrap
up this lesson here but you'll notice
that we need to convert alpha
ketoglutarate to the amine this is going
to be the exact reverse of this process
and the first step involves alpha
ketoglutarate condensing with this amine
to form an amine see if you can try this
mechanism on your own and I'll show it
to you sometime in a future lesson KP
here if you learn something give me a
thumbs up on the way out and for more
chemistry subscribe to my channel